deep within Europe lies the continent's
most powerful business Dynasty their
family tree includes Bankers
industrialists politicians bureaucrats
diplomats military officials they own
everything from AstraZeneca to the
NASDAQ Stock Exchange they own more than
a third of Sweden's entire Stock
Exchange their web of companies employ
over a million people including almost
half of Sweden's entire industrial
Workforce in the 70s and today their
empire spans more than 275 billion
dollars far exceeding Jeff Bezos Elon
Musk or even Bernard are no they've got
ties to the richest most powerful people
in the world from the White House to the
world economic Forum this Clan has their
tentacles everywhere and yet you've
probably never heard of their name you
won't find a single one of them on the
force billionaire list and that's
because they've worked very hard to stay
in the shadows hardly ever making any
public appearances or interviews why
because getting to the top is messy and
getting to the point where you own the
entire continent of Europe you're gonna
have a lot of skeletons in your closet
that you'd rather not have the masses
know abouts we don't want to stroke up
any Envy or any Anti-Trust talk now
would we stay dangerous and say hello to
the wallenbergs the family that owns all
of Europe shout out to this member of
the channel for suggesting this video
idea and let me know what video I should
do next in the comments below
[Music]
foreign
if you happen to run an online store or
an e-commerce business and you're
looking to save more time and money with
shipping then you have to check out
shipstation shipstation is hands down
the best way to ship because it allows
you to automate and streamline your
entire shipping process while saving you
up to 84 from Top carriers like UPS USPS
and DHL Express over 130 000 Merchants
use shipstation and 98 of companies that
use shipstation for a year end up using
it for life you can connect to almost
any selling Channel you can think of
they've got scam-based workflows bulk
updates and automation processes to ship
your orders super fast you can compare
race and then print labels and batches
and shipstation will even instant update
the tracking information to the selling
Channel and the customer wants an order
ships you'll even get free comprehensive
onboarding support to get you shipping
faster right away and you can get
started by going to shipstation.com for
a 60-day free trial that's two months of
Cheaper simpler shipping completely for
free go to shiftstation.com with the
link below right now thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
foreign
was one of the worst Financial crises
America had experience at that time
falling cotton prices bad Harvest and
inflation LED Banks to fail businesses
to go bankrupt and unemployment to
Skyrocket it was a nightmare for
American Bankers but it was a very
important lesson for a young naval
officer from Sweden his name was Andre
Oscar Wallenberg and in 1837 he had a
front row seat to witness the chaos in
America first hand the incompetence of
American Banks and bankers gave Andre
Wallenberg an idea he had clearly seen
how Banks should not be run and he
wondered why he couldn't just take what
he learned back to his homeland to open
up a better Bank over there he also saw
a massive opportunity Swedish Banks were
missing out on see Swedish banks at the
time were archaic it was hard to
transfer money between locations you
couldn't get a high interest rate for
depositing your money but most
importantly Swedish banks at the time
didn't take the money people deposited
into their savings accounts to lend out
to other companies Swedish Banks were
not lending to other companies during a
time when Sweden was in the midst of
industrialization corporations were
becoming a thing multi National
corporations were becoming a thing
Swedish railroad network was being built
and Sweden's economy was skyrocketing
all these opportunities needed funding
but none of the existing Banks were
meeting the need
[Music]
think about just how big of an
opportunity this was today the idea of
banks taking your deposits and lending
it out like crazy is the norm it's why
they're so rich and Powerful it's what
led to the 2008 financial crisis but
back then in Sweden Banks were not
participating in this financial Alchemy
when it was the best time to participate
so they were leaving an insane amount of
money on the table and if Andre
Wallenberg could go back to Europe and
establish a new modern Bank he could
have the potential to become the most
powerful Banker in all of Sweden and the
great thing was back in the 1800s the
banking sector was very different from
what it is today today one doesn't
simply decide to go and open up a bank
today's banking sector is so regulated
it requires so much Capital that's
almost impossible to do unless you
either partner with an existing bank or
you're already rich and Powerful to
begin with and side note this huge
barrier to entry is by Design the big
Banks don't want anyone else opening up
shop to compete but luckily for Andre
wellenberg 200 years ago banking was the
Wild West anyone could open up shop and
start shackling people in debt you could
open up a bank as easily as you could
open up a jewelry store or or a doctor's
office so with the help of his
colleagues Andre Wallenberg managed to
open up the Stockholm and skill the bank
or Seb in 1856 and the Seb was unlike
anything Sweden has seen before it
encouraged the public average everyday
Joes to deposit their heart earned money
into savings accounts these savings
accounts offered actually good interest
rates so the longer you left your money
in your savings account the more
interest it could earn you so the masses
flocked to Seb again this sounds very
normal today but back then this wasn't
something that was available to the
average person in Sweden but just like
today little did those customers know
that the money they put in the bank
wasn't being kept safe for you and a big
vault in the back no Wallenberg would
then take your money and then lend it
out to other people and businesses
during the best possible time to be
lending out money in Sweden during
industrialization
and for Wallenberg it was a gold rush
the Seb became so popular that it
quickly took over Sweden's entire
banking industry Sweden had become
conquered but not by a foreign power but
a domestic one and the weapon of choice
was banking suddenly the Swedish people
either had their money with Wallenberg
or they were slaving a way to pay out
the debt they owe to Wallenberg and the
way they slave the way to pay back the
debt was by working for a company that
owed money to Wallenberg it was genius
but the wallenbergs didn't stop there
sure their family fortune was growing at
an exponential rates but they're Bankers
they know they can't just let all this
cash sit there not working for them but
where to invest all this cash why not
just buy all the companies in Sweden
that way the entire population of Sweden
would have their money deposited with
the wallenbergs they would also owe
money to the wallenbergs and to pay off
that debt they would have to get up
every day in the morning and go to work
for a Wallenberg company a Wallenberg
company that owned money too you guessed
it the wallenbergs it was simply the
last logical step in the financial
enslavement of Sweden and it would
Propel the Wallenberg family into the
one percent of not just Sweden but the
entire world
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
family started buying majority stakes
and hundreds of Swedish companies they
call it quote the liberal transformation
of Swedish Society End quotes from
Railways to factories to international
trade and LLCs there was not a major
company in Sweden that the wallenbergs
didn't have some stake in but in 1916
they ran into a problem the Swedish
government started seeing the danger of
allowing Banks to own major businesses
while also getting those businesses and
people in debt to them so the Swedish
government passed a law that made it
nearly impossible for banks to own
long-term shares of industrial
businesses but the wallenbergs weren't
so quick to give up so to get around
this new law the Wallenberg family
created investor a b a very vague
sounding holding company that was given
full ownership of all the businesses
their bank owned investor a b became the
wallenberg's personal investment arm and
the crisis was averted The Firm did so
well that by the 1970s the Wallenberg
family employed more than 40 percent of
Sweden's entire industrial Workforce and
owned 40 of the country's entire Stock
Exchange there wasn't a single aspect of
the banking cycle the one our family
didn't profit from but then came World
War II
and the wallenbergs were left with a
decision which side of the war would
they profit from the Allies or Hitler so
the Wallenberg decided to take a page
out of the rush house Playbook and said
foreign
earlier the Rothschild had gone down the
history books for Lending money to both
sides of wars that way no matter which
side won both sides became indebted to
you and you always come out on top
that's why as a banker you always want
to play Both Sides watch our full
documentary on the Rothschild dynasty by
clicking the card in the top right
corner right now to learn more and this
was a lesson the wallenbergs took to
heart when World War II came around on
one side they had Germany who was facing
strict sanctions and the possibility of
losing billions of dollars as the Allies
shut down their businesses on the other
hand they had America and Britain who
desperately needed banking services in
Europe to continue fighting so here's
what they did while one Wallenberg
brother dealt with the Allies in London
and New York offering their Bank
services to their War efforts the other
brothers stationed himself in Berlin
there the wallenbergs offered to buy
important German military supply
companies like Bosch to prevent them
from being seized or shut down by the
Allah technically it was legal to buy
these companies if you intended to keep
them and use them according to the law
but what the wallenbergs were doing was
very different instead of buying and
keeping these companies they signed
agreements that stated that they
promised to sell the companies back to
Germany as soon as Germany wanted them
back in exchange for a fat fee of course
not only did the Wallenberg family keep
Germany's most important company safe
from the Allies in exchange for money
they went to extreme lengths like
running black market operations and
money laundering to ensure that they
could keep making money on both sides of
the war now it would be unfair not to
mention that one Wallenberg Raul
Wallenberg actually saved between four
thousand and thirty five thousand Jews
during World War II by issuing them
Swedish papers he later died in prison
after being captured by the Soviet Union
but playing both sides became so
profitable for the Wallenberg family
that more than 50 years later they were
still using the exact same Playbook the
wallenberg's own Ericsson a
multinational Telecom company and won a
certain violent organization in the
Middle East that rhymes with crisis
threatened to shut down one of eris's
transfer routes in Iraq Erickson simply
paid the violent organization tens of
millions of dollars in bribes to
guarantee their safety after Russia
invaded Ukraine in 2014 and got slapped
with every sanction known to man the
company's Atlas Copco and SKF both
companies the wallenbergs hold stakes in
continued to sell crucial equipment to
Russian nuclear weapons programs but now
the family was faced with another
existential crisis solving the problem
of past
wealth see although having Rich parents
may sound tempting most kids that come
from Rich families are dead inside they
have no purpose no drive that's why 9
out of 10 of the world's richest
families lose their wealth by the third
generation there's a famous quote that
sums us up my grandfather walked 10
miles to work every day my father walked
five I'm driving a Cadillac my son is in
a Mercedes my grandson will be in a
Ferrari but my great-grandson will be
walking again so the Wallenberg family
had to find a way to escape the curse
the curse of the third generation
thank you
foreign
passing down the entire Wallenberg
family fortune to one or two sons most
of their money is kept in family run
foundations while dozens of family heirs
are each put in charge of different
foundations and businesses that make up
their vast Empire that way no one single
era has the power to single-handedly
destroy the entire family fortune and
before any of the Wallenberg family
members reach a management position
they're required to actually spend time
working in the company to gain real life
experience this careful methodical
approach to passing on wealth and
companies that the wallenbergs took is
basically the exact opposite of what the
Vanderbilts did the Vanderbilt Dynasty
came to power at around the same time as
the wallenbergs and the Vanderbilts
actually became the richest family in
the entire world beating up the
wallenbergs by a long shot but Cornelius
Vayner built the family's patriarch
didn't trust his family with his
business or money he had 13 kids but
instead of mentoring all of them to
divide up his wealth he left his entire
Fortune to just one of his sons the rest
of his kids got practically nothing and
at first it worked it his son ended up
doubling the family fortune but from
that point on it was all downhill his
son also didn't take a very methodical
approach to passing down the money so
the rest of the family only knew how to
spend money mansion's lavish parties
Yachts you name it they bought it so
within just 50 years of the patriarch's
death the entire 200 billion dollar
Fortune had completely vanished when 120
members of the Vanderbilt family met for
a family reunion in 1973 not a single
one of them was a millionaire and we
break down how the Vanderbilts lost
their entire fortune in a new video on
our new Spanish channel so if you're
mainly a Spanish speaker or you have
friends and family that only speak
Spanish so you've never been able to
share these videos with them now you can
click the card on the screen to watch
and share with them now click the card
on the screen to watch and share now